welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 16 the
mid-season finale first a quick shout
out to this video's sponsor the amc the
walking dead shop that's where you can
get some super sweet official the
walking dead merch and stay tuned after
the recap as i unbox one of their supply
drop subscription boxes it's gonna be
fun so maggie and friends are leaving
the hilltop because they know lance
hornsby is coming for him and indeed
he's hired the last reaper leia to
assassinate maggie giving her some of
the commonwealth troops on this off the
books mission maggie meets up with the
survivors of the apartment complex
including negan and his pregnant wife
maggie's like hey i gotta go fight can
you guys babysit little herschel and
it's a breakthrough moment for maggie
and negan she's like look man i'm
starting to trust you not forgiving you
but trust you just then something
unexpected happens we've got a swarm of
locusts yeah it's a random act of god to
set the mood here for this mid-season
finale with the eerie buzzing in the
background now daryl aaron and gabriel
have been sent off with some of the
commonwealth troops to go look for the
missing guns but when they get to this
abandoned car junkyard they all notice
the commonwealth troopers are
surrounding them yes lance hornsby's
decided to have them killed so now's the
time to fight back and it's a big
shootout in the junkyard we haven't had
a big gunfight in a while that night at
hilltop the commonwealth strike team's
coming in but what's this no one's here
except a bomb yeah maggie booby-trapped
the place she finally had to admit
hilltop was not gonna be fixed but of
course leah survived and she chases
maggie out into the woods where for a
long stretch of the episode all these
characters are just walking around in
the dark and i can't really see anything
meanwhile back at the commonwealth first
of all confirmed eugene and max get it
on congrats eugene you're no longer the
40 year old virgin now max is on her
mission to find some incriminating
documents about pamela milton and
especially her son sebastian just then
sebastian walks in and he seems to be on
some substances max is worried he's
gonna notice she's taken some classified
documents but i'm mostly worried he's
gonna make a clumsy move and try to kiss
her now they assemble the team to check
out these documents and it seems like a
lot of the same names from the list they
had before with numbers that are like
maybe a code about where they're being
moved we still really don't know what's
going on but they figure it's enough to
write an expose for now that's like
pamela milton's lying to you so pamela
milton is real mad and the start of a
commonwealth revolution is started out
in the woods the midnight game of hide
and seek finally comes to an end when
leah gets to jump on maggie she doesn't
kill her immediately of course she ties
her up so they can have a nice
conversation where it's like i'm gonna
kill everyone you love first maggie
escapes and it turns into a fight these
two girls going at it it looks like
leah's gonna win is this the end for
maggie but oh someone shoots her yes it
was daryl come back to kill his
ex-girlfriend and save magster but now
lance hornsby has found them too so
daryl immediately takes a shot at him
and oh grazes his cheek and so our crew
has somewhat won the day they've all
survived for now at least they're not
necessarily fugitives of the
commonwealth it's unclear how much lance
has been reporting back but because this
is his secret mission gone wrong
probably not much but lance hornsby does
not like losing he doesn't retreat he
doubles down and occupies alexandria
yeah no more mr nice guy he's got his
stormtroopers occupying hilltop too and
he also goes to oceanside which don't
forget still exists he rounds up
everyone here and pulls out his lucky
coin gives it a flip yeah lance hornsby
with the coin and the scar he's turned
into a two-face would he go so far as to
execute all of oceanside find out on the
next episode of the walking dead the
final part of the final season and we're
back with round two of the amc the
walking dead universe shop supply
dropbox unboxing if you were here last
week you know i've got this awesome
commonwealth sweatshirt now next up what
other goodies do we have inside oh you
know that box that's a funko pop it's
carol look at that one right there oh
man this is a good outfit for her
actually just a little bit of blood
spatter on the face there okay yeah this
is cool this is a supply drop exclusive
so if you want uh cool blood stained a
bow carol this is the only way to get it
what other goodies await us here i've
got something new right here
it is the air freshener always necessary
for cars and such and there it is the
taste of tradition uh the commonwealth
ice cream shop uh where eugene famously
just like
melted it all over his hands like an
idiot let me pop this bad boy over here
and give it a whiff
oh that's good stuff and last but what
looks like something super cool this is
a canvas art
featuring daryl hanging this on the wall
of the mana recap studio right away let
me bust it on open here and show you
guys oh
snap
look at that it's the canvas so it feels
real good and uh i mean look how awesome
that is that's our boy daryl
throughout the seasons i love that
artwork this is that's really cool yeah
okay that's a winner and check this out
this is just one of four of the supply
drop box exclusives there i guess
they're gonna feature some other
characters throughout the year so sign
up now make sure you get them all so
there you have it the quarter one supply
drop box from the amc the walking dead
universe shop sign up now while quarter
one is still going so you make sure you
get all this stuff so that way end of
the year you've got the full package of
exclusives the links in the description
to make it real easy for you so this is
super cool and thanks for unboxing with
me
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]